drugs should be legal
not just marijuana today's 420. i don't
know what are your thoughts on
legalization of marijuana well i'm sad
to see
that uh who was it willie willie uh
nelson willie nelson
wants the president to make it a
national holiday a national week
do we have to make everything about
government can't you just enjoy weed
but it's once you're an adult do you own
your body
or not isn't isn't my right you've got
your tequila here if i want to poison
myself with your tequila
that's the rock's tequila shout out to
the rock it should be our choice
right so that's a libertarian by the way
if they make 420
a national holiday for wheat 4 20
also happens to be hitler's birthday so
before they decide to make 4
20 a national holiday they might want to
think twice on making
the man's birthday a national flipping
holiday
may not be a good idea i agree with you
good point i did not know that yeah
420 can you imagine that you make that
the birthdates it's a pretty pathetic
situation
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye